Hey, Andy. How'd it go?
>> It went okay.
I have two cats and
it's working, but the whole process was a little frustrating.
>> Frustrating in what way?
>> So you're not going to like this, but I.
>> oh. >> Basically just copied and
pasted all my code from, you know, the first cat, made a second cat.
Had a cat one and a cat two.
Account one and account two and all that sort of thing.
>> It seems like a quick and easy method, right?
>> It was quick, but it wasn't easy.
>> Why? Wait, why not?
>> So I forgot to change one of the ones to a two, and so
when I clicked on one of the cats, it kept incrementing both of the cats, and
that isn't the best, the best way to do things.
>> I see.
Now here's another question.
If hypothetically, I were to ask you to scale this from two cats to say,
five cats.
What would you say?
Like, does it, is it scalable?
>> Part of me wants to say no.
[LAUGH] I don't want to do that.
[LAUGH]. >> But this method probably wouldn't, and I,
obviously this method would not be the best way to do it.
sure, it could work.
I would probably want to find a better way to do it.
>> That's probably a wise approach.
Yeah.
Now if I were hypothetically to ask you and Andy to do this, and
scale up to five cats, there is one thing that you probably should be aware of,
and that has to do with closures.
When you're adding eventless centers to elements, several elements,
in a closure inside of a loop, there's an easy trap you can fall into.
Now, the next node is going to be a reading node.
It's going to tell you information about when you might fall into that trap, and
how to get out of it.